so this morning we're gonna see
something on on the let's say integer
programming side mixed with a little bit
of fixed parameter tractability which is
different than let's say the focus of
the previous talks in days so it's my
pleasure to introduce clarkson he's a
professor at the university of Kiel and
he's going to talk to us about intricate
programming in condoms thanks for the
introduction
so this is joint work with my former PhD
student Lazo vera who's now in Lausanne
about integer program convolution so the
main focus is here we look at integer
linear programs in a standard form and
the considered case what we looked at is
where the number of constraints in the
matrix is a parameter or a fixed
constant and the entries of the matrix
are also small bounded by some parameter
data so we will see some applications
where especially we get such forms for
instance knapsack problem scheduling
problems on identical and uniform
machines and we're also some other where
you try to find some approximation
algorithms using some configuration
eyepiece you usually get such type of
integer linear programs sometimes also a
bit more complicated versions so we had
also some papers where you get some n
fold structures so but this is a quite
nice interesting case
so what's known about this case so maybe
I should mention so the typical thing
for what people looked at is if the
number of variables is concerned so
there a gross balance archanan where you
know they're run in a in a reasonable
running time but for if the number of
constraints is small for instance only
one when you don't have these second
restriction you have already the
knapsack problem and you have an np-hard
problem so that's more difficult here
there
so what's known so we're to a Grimm's
one by papademetriou in the 80s so we
had a running time Alegre with the
running time where we have M square M
was the number of constraints in the
exponent and recently this was improved
by eyes upon advice mantle using some
other techniques but also we'll show you
in the talk where you have here a
dependence only of 2m in the exponent
times the right hand side and the number
of variables so what we did is we
improved slightly on this so you know
what you can do is you can avoid the
term in here so you get use it only as
pre-processing and instead of the
right-hand side so the largest value on
the large right hand side you use only a
logarithmic of this and that's also
useful what we see later
for feasibility and proximity results
furthermore so we looked at also can we
improve this further so what happens if
you would like to have something with
two - data here in the exponent and we
were able to show that this is somehow
equivalent to finding a subreddit
genetic algorithm for the so called min
plus convolution problem so now we
discussed it also there's some
assumption that you cannot do that it's
our quadratic time otherwise there is a
collection of problems where you get
improvements
so that's one thing the second part is
we looked also at the feasibility
problem so where we don't have an
objective function here it's quite nice
so the exponent gets down to M instead
of 2m and here we have also a lower
bound so if you would try to get
something with m- data here in the
exponent that would contradict the
strong exponential time hypothesis I
will show you this yet so and this was
also started by Aizen behind and vice
mantle where they have a similar
dependence here this is the right hand
side without the square and here we have
also the log term and so the other
results are which discuss also later in
detail so we looked at unbounded version
of knapsack or subset sum problem where
the parameter is here there makes a move
weight of the items and C is the
capacity of the knapsack so we if you
look at the literature that were the
previous result what you had able the
capacity goes inside and that was
improved to Delta square times N and
unbound it was a bit better so and we
could avoid somehow the dependence here
on C we could improve this slightly and
this also unbounded means that items you
can take several times without their
limit no you have numbers you would have
you can take number several times but
you would have the capacity exactly and
the other application what also we
discussed later is the scheduling
problem where I worked a lot on so the
previous result what I had is with
fasciae and Kim and with Linus so we had
to EP toss EP toss means where the the
running time is a function in one of
epsilon plus something that's polynomial
in the other parameters that it was the
previous result with the lock to the
power four inside in the exponent
and using these egg rooms what we found
is we could improve this also to to it's
much easier as before the NSA number
here of jobs and what do you mean for
the for the problem before for which
problem yeah if if the right hand side
is quite large we see that also we had
some there were also some proximity
results where you can reduce the right
hand side later on but avoiding the end
term there is helps also and you see we
can also get faster results then using
the proximity afterwards yeah yeah
that's what you would see later whenever
just you will see I think so yeah mm-hmm
so what is the main idea also already by
eyes upon advisement that's quite nice
it's a so-called Steinitz lemma that's
used heavily here so you can take any
norm here in to the end and you have a
collection of vectors we are the norm of
the vector all the vectors is at most
one and if you sum up all the vectors
you get the zero vector then you can
prove that there is a permutation of
your vectors so that all partial sums
here are bounded by the dimension by M
and that's quite nice no and it was
proved by the vasana and others and you
can also find a nice proof in the paper
by item and vice members the main idea
is the following assume that you have a
path here that goes from the origin back
you can reorder the vectors so you are
that you always are in a box of demand
of value emptier and how you can you you
can use that so look at an optimum
solution of the IP X star then you say
okay I pick X 1 star times the first
column X 2 x star the second color etc
and recall in our case or the the norms
are bounded by data because it was the
largest entry and it was an optimum
solution of this here what you can do
now is you can if you have now here you
have a path from 0 to the right-hand
side B and you can reorder this now so
that you get a path that's very close to
the to the diagonal between from 0 to B
so they are not far away from this is
that what what you will use afterwards
okay so how you can do that proof this
formally this also not so complicated
you look at the columns of a where your
some your sum is B that's your optimum
solution then you can find a permutation
where the partial sums are close to the
diagonal B divided by T by a bound to M
Delta and the it works as follows
you take these vectors here VI minus the
right-hand side divided by the number of
vectors and then you have to scale it by
two Delta because why VI divided by
Delta is at most 1 and B divided by
Delta is also bounded by by one so you
get the norms of the vectors are one in
the infinity norm and then if you plug
that in that comes directly out of this
so yes repeated copies no you saw you
take your optimum solution here then you
see directly that this works so how you
can use this now you look at all the
corresponding vectors here that are
close to the diagonal and then you have
to compute the longest path here from 0
to B so an optimum solutions the longest
path the feasibility is a path here the
vertices how many vertices do you have
so we have something like m Delta to the
M because we have a vector of dimension
M times the largest entry in B and the
number of edges so how do you get an
edge so we connect two vectors if the
difference is a column here and the way
it gives you the length of the edge here
and then you see directly that you gain
with the longest path you can generate
here is an optimum solution so the
running time is the number of vertices
times the edges therefore you get this
that's the main idea but just some other
thing what's quite interesting you can
also see there there is an optimum
solution where the norm is bounded
you don't have more than the number of
vertices here in your path and that
means the one normal is here bounded by
this term and this also used later how
can you improve this so the idea is
somehow that you take your path and then
you look at a position somewhere in the
middle after T over 2 times number of
vectors so we take again here the
columns corresponding to an optimum
solution here and then we know that the
first T by T over 2 vectors together is
this is optimum for the right-hand side
B Prime and these the other vectors are
optimal for B minus B Prime
where B prime is somehow close to the
point 1 over B divided by 2 and it
follows directly based on its Lamar also
that both of the vectors are not too far
from here because of the partial sum now
the partial sum is is bounded here by
this and that's what you can use then so
how does it work so finally we use a
dynamic program to solve the presen
because of the bound with the the
optimum solution let me see that again
so we have these the bound here for the
one norm of your our optimum solution
you can make this a bit larger to go to
the next X exponent of 2 assume that the
norm is 2 to the K and K is then this
lock term here so if you plug this in
you get this the value here for the
bound of the optimum solution and if you
take the lock this is the number of
iterations what we have to use later so
on the idea is to go stepwise you start
with norm one two
etc until you reach the optimum solution
it is sufficient only to take the
smaller solution connected later this
you can use the other solution again
above so what we solve now is it roughly
so you look at all right hand side that
are close here to the diagonal by these
values it's a bit larger as what we have
understand its lemma you see later why
why is that why do you need this and we
solve this problem here with this
modified right hand side this one norm
here and you see if you plug in for
instance I equals 0 you get the original
problem and what you do is here for one
you have one is it also interesting so
if you plug the first iteration for K
inside you get 2 to the 0 this is 1 that
means you take only one configuration
it's quite easy in initialization yeah
then you look for two you connect two
configurations at etc and that's also
where you use the convolution step later
you convolute solutions of two ways
together that they form the
corresponding values so while you do we
use this value here for the bound so
suppose we have one iteration i we have
a right hand side that's close to the
diagonal with value for M Delta and that
means we have a solution here with this
right hand side with these vectors so
with the optimum solution order by the
steinitz lemma and what you do is now
you take half of the vectors here a look
at beep double prime and then you look
how far is B Double prime away from the
next iteration so if you have to I pass
one in the the denominator
and then you can split this in two parts
for the first part we know by the
steinitz lemma that the difference is
to mdhil and for the other part by
assumption here we had this distance is
4 M Delta but you can scale it with 1 1
over 2 so in total that we get here also
for M data that's the reason why we use
this because then you have the if we
have solution for this and also the
solution for this here that you can
prove in the similar way then you get
solutions for these above that's the
reason why we have to add the value of 2
here so finally what you do is by the
convolution you guess the value would be
double Prime and you have only a limited
number of candidates for this because
they are close to the diagonal then you
look at the solutions for V double Prime
in the previous step and for the
remaining part also and then you connect
both solutions so it's a merging of
different types
so let us look how how the convolution
works so in general the coluche
convolution is defined as follows you
have a sequence of numbers one sequence
error and one sequence yes and you would
like to compute the values T I where T
is the maximum of the combinations where
the sum of the indices this gives here
this I value so that means you connect
this value and take the best over oil
and if you look at our case if M is only
one with only one constraint then this
directly corresponds to max plus
convolution where the size here is the
number of candidates in this case and
for general M you can also cast this you
can also do the same and get a size of
the number of candidates what's a bit
larger so if then you have not only
single elements but vectors what you
have to combine okay and what's what's
known for this some interesting thing if
you have an a grim form in plus
convolution that's a similar as a
similar running time in class of Bank
Max plus makes no difference here what
you get is here now the following so the
size here is the number of candidates so
we have this running time stumble times
the number of iterations what we have
plus some pre-processing at the
beginning where you have to eliminate
some mm elements and that gives you the
running time for the individual in your
program so what you can do is for
instance
so the convolution step can be solved in
n square time or even a bit faster so
one possibility is to plug in n square
divided by log N and then you get such a
running time finally by inserting and
calculating this okay that's one thing
so this shows you how that how we get
the running time here
it's trivial but this is great login
requires more yeah there's some recent
papers but people looked at how to
improve this it's like no no it's also
more involved yeah and there's also some
further results
slightly better as this okay that's one
way but you can also get the way back
and there is how we can prove a lower
bound there's some so what we were able
to prove is is that if you have an
algorithm where the running time is 2m
minus theta in the exponent here then
you can prove that the min past
convolution can be solved in sub
quadratic time there are some recent
papers about how how to connect these
problems with the collection of other
problems in spice Egon at all they had
an iconic paper about this one case was
for instance that the min pass
convolution is related to the unbounded
knapsack problem where C is the capacity
here yes it works also for generally we
see that I show you how the how that
works sir it's not complicated
no so this here this was proof by
singing at all what we did is one thing
is you can relate the unbounded knapsack
problem directly for m equal 1 and then
you can generalize it for larger m where
you saw it so let me show how it works
it's not complicated so you have
unbounded knapsack so we have a capacity
at most see these are the profit values
here you will see ok d you can take item
several times that means the if you have
here the unbounded limit and what you
simply do is you add some extra variable
to get equality constraint and then if m
is 1 and you assume that you have such a
running time you see all the values are
data the capacity is the right hand side
so this is o of c and then if m is 1 you
directly this here this is not
complicated no bit more interesting is
the case if M is larger so the idea is
here to reduce the data by additional
equalities that works as follows you do
you use something like carry over as an
idea behind this so you're right here
your capacity and your weights something
like doing numbers but with a different
basis so the basis is the new data our
value is the capacity to the M square of
this and then you see all the values
here are bounded now also the capacity
parts and one constraint like this you
can write as a sequence of equal
equalities we are used to carry over
here somehow with an extra variable that
goes from here to the next constraint
etc you couldn't prove that both things
are equivalent so the nice thing is now
the coefficients are all smaller now as
the original coefficients and the
coefficients are now this here so then
you see that you can do that suppose for
a fixed M you have an algorithm which
such a running time so the our
construction shows that we can solve
this now the biggest entry is this here
so and if you plug this in so data and
the right hand side are bounded now by
this and so we have one term that
depends only on M you can move this out
and the rest the M is cancelled out so
we get you get a function in M times
little bit slightly better than the
capacity so that works at least if M is
fixed constant little bit more
complicated this M is larger than you
don't get directly a contradiction so
that means an unbounded Epps that can be
solved in some erratic time and then
also min pass convolution
so if M is fixed so we have a fixed
number of constraints there's no chance
yes this is by seeker there was also
another paper they did similar things
okay
feasibility is a bit easier because the
convolution gets simpler because we have
only to check is their solution we don't
have to look at the best longest path
that means in the convolution you get
boolean values here or values 0 and 1 we
get a boolean operation here this is
easier to solve use Fourier
transformation in n log n time and if
you plug this in you get directly you
see that it goes faster so the
feasibility was this running time what
we had so an instead of M square you get
M here then no and the rest is only by
inserting different is the convolution
only here is similar as before yeah
and here you can also prove a lower
bound and what the interesting is there
was a beta by Abu and others I think
they published it this year last year in
soda and they proved it but the result
was known already some time ago so this
is the the proof to following for the K
sum problem the following version so we
have a parameter T and then collection
of numbers K subsets here where and the
the sum of all the elements is n then
you asked is there possibility to choose
an element from each set so that the sum
of the various give is exactly the value
T here and they prove the very nice
result it gives it helps us a lot
there proved here if the strong ATH
holds then there's no algorithm for K
sum with this running time so the the
nice thing is the dependence on
also here t1 minus Delta and the
polynomial in n and this you can use
here directly to prove that there is no
agram for the feasibility problem where
you get a running time of n - FM and
this here to the power of M minus Delta
and what do you get her in
so you it is so if you would like to
improve here this by a little amount but
by some fixed data here so you can show
that it's not possible even if you take
your very large value the function in
this is this is linear in n it's this
outside also you can even have it the
reduction shows you that is much higher
here it's not important the important
thing is this here now you cannot
improve the exponent here further it's
quite nice we have a ragam and also
about lower bound for this I will not go
into details of it technically this part
but I will show you something else
proximity because it was also done by
isin one advise button and you can
connect this also with our egg room to
improve further so look at an integer
linear program where we know this is a
at least as a feasible solution this is
bounded and then you look at an optimal
solution of your LP relaxation then they
were able to prove that there is an
optimum solution for the IRP where the
difference with to the optimum peace
solution is bounded by this term and it
helps you also further because what you
can do is you can reduce the right hand
side because you know if your IP value
is larger than this amount then you know
that this has also some amount on the
corresponding variable there so that
means you can see that this value has at
least this amount corresponding to the
LP value and if you plug this in you see
as a consequence that you can reduce
your right hand side also and so if you
plug this in
they proof then optimality and
feasibility
can be done in such a running time so
with four M plus two in the exponent and
two M plus one here so you see you avoid
here the right hand side the B the B
value B infinity is here not two if you
plug this in you convert this but nice
is we have a lock term there and then it
goes even faster that means using our
result we get such such a running time
so here to M here plus the running time
of the LP in this case you get M plus
the running time of the LP and AP is
usually faster here that's quite nice to
your proximity K you can also use to
further reduce your running time so and
now I will come to the applications so
the unbounded knapsack problem what you
can use is here is the feasibility
problem is sufficient for the for the
unbounded subset sum problem your
feasibility for the other the other one
the LP is quite easy in both cases if
you look at the fraction knapsack or
cetera then you can use it in such a
running time if you know that if your
double elements you would avoid this no
so otherwise you get an N extra here at
additive subset sum is even easier
because you can take one element simply
and take it completely with a fractional
value so that gives goes in constant
time and if you plug this in you get
directly these running times here for
both versions its data's clear or data
times log n log square Delta for the
problems
this and the the other result so I
worked a lot on the scheduling problem
so we have jobs here and there's also
somehow where I get into this because I
you can see later the IEP what you get
especially this form what we have so we
have n jobs we have M machines they have
some processing times here are your jobs
the colored means here somehow the the
sizes of the jobs and what you would
like to find as a schedule so assignment
of jobs to the machine where you
minimize the maximum load on the
machines and so that means how somehow
distribution of your jobs here and you
would like to minimize the makespan to
max the maximum load on here and so the
the idea the main idea is the following
your first there I have some
pre-processing steps at the beginning
use an approximation I go usually with a
constant pound then you have an interval
where you know that where the optimal
value is in between then you use a
binary search over this and for a fixed
value of the max pain you distinguish
between large and small jobs those small
jobs you can remove directly you can add
them simply at the end and for the big
jobs you do some rounding and the
rounding gives you so many job sizes
afterwards so it's a combination of
arithmetic and geometric rounding of
your job sizes and then you use a
configuration a P that means for for you
use a variable for each mighty set so a
combination of jobs that you can put on
one machine with the corresponding max
20 and then you get these IRP and I here
is the number of jobs of a specific size
M is the number of machines and then you
see the thing the number of variants is
quite large is exponential in 1 over
epsilon so many mighty sets you could
have but what's nice is the right hand
side is bounded and also the values here
in your busy eyes here because each side
if you have only large sizes you can
take only one of our epsilon times and
the the largest value here is the number
of jobs in the worst case n so and you
what we did before is we had a running
time like this and we used a if you use
the algorithm here now it gets much
easier directly so using some
pre-processing that goes also linear
time so we were able to improve this but
this is another story you get this
running time here finally by simply
plugging in the results for the
feasibility problem and so you see here
see these are the number of candidates
this is the it was for the feasibility
problem these was the number of
iterations plus some pre-processing at
the beginning
plus the pre-processing for the
scheduling problem and if you insert
this you get this what's interesting
here is there is also lower bound for
the scheduling problem so you don't have
if the ETH holds you don't have an egg
room where you improve this here with 1
over epsilon this is not possible the
only possibility is simply to make maybe
the lock term a bit smaller and we have
some recent paper that comes out soon
where we you can also avoid this make
this a bit smaller by having only one
lakh times some lock lock term but they
do some further ideas for the lower
bound we use there yeah yeah we proved
this sometime ago with a head of student
from Hangzhou Lin Chen and his adviser
were able to prove lower bound for the
scheduling problem even for the
approximation algorithm
okay that's it so I conclude now so what
we have seen is an improved pseudo
polynomial time algorithm for the number
of constraints OMS goes here some on the
exponent we have an equivalence to the
min past convolution problem we have
also a lower bound for the feasibility
ILP under the SAT edge so you can also
use the proximity results to reduce the
running time and we have some
application in scheduling problem and
also the website problems that's also
somehow so my main area is working on
the scheduling problem and entered
somehow by accident here the integer
programming part so there are some open
question at the end this is also
mentioned already by isin bon advice
Monta so if you have a bit more general
integer linear program where you have
also upper and lower bounds on your
variables then things does not work so
easily so the best algorithm here has a
silly dependence on M Square and the
question is can you do that even also
faster to get your M or a bit faster as
M Square
[Applause]
yes there are some other dynamic
programming problems where there's
property yeah I saw there's a paper
where they could solve for a knapsack on
some other variants of the problem the
convolution step faster using if you
came they could prove that they have
some special property they're not
directly monk but similarly similar
where the the convolution gets even in
linear time yeah it was a paper last
year I cut where they had such a result
like other interesting parameters other
than Delta that you could put on these
matrices maybe for instance you couldn't
look at the largest determinant what you
have now they should also go faster yeah
if there are no more questions that's
thanks
[Applause]
but with sometimes that is